dude I just want to get wins like I
don't need to change culture like I need
to change my bank account and my
lifestyle like there's these companies
like Tesla and basically a lot of stuff
that Elon does which is like this like
super sexy stuff I mean I'm not
interested in in it but it is quite sexy
to say you're gonna send a you're gonna
go to Mars or you're creating these cars
that are neat and fun and that whenever
I think about these companies they're
like the coolest companies where you
create a hype video at the end of the
year and you see everything they've done
and you're like oh my god that's so sick
like when they created like a video of
Elon celebrating the one of his rock is
taking off house like and so anyway
constantly things not that he doesn't do
a video him like looking at his Golf
Club software right and it's pretty
boring but it's still fascinating
because like a fun puzzle how do you
Shawn about like where are your
aspirations like do you say like I want
to do something that's full of
excitement or do you find excitement in
the boring so I used to be a pretty
hardcore about this where I was like
dude the only thing worth doing like if
I'm gonna spend my time and I used to be
really like dismissive of people who
were wasting their time doing things
that were not sort of the peak of the
peak so I was like okay if I'm gonna do
why would I do a job when I can own my
own business then I was like why would I
own a small business when I can own a
big business they both kind of take up
all my energy my time and it's like I'm
gonna do a big business why would I do a
boring thing might as well do an
exciting thing and that train of logic
made sense to me and I did that so at
Monkey inferno it was we are here to try
to create the next hit consumer thing
we're like we don't give a that
that's low odds of success we want to
create you know Michael had created Bebo
and which was like sort of like almost
Facebook he had like come within sort of
inches of creating a Facebook but
instead ended up in the myspace pile and
you know did well financially but he
didn't change culture and so we were
like dude we can do this we could change
culture and so we tried every you know
messaging apps live streaming we tried
all these different consumer things
and failed like crazy and you know even
things that like kind of worked they
ultimately were not successful because
there was they were so homerun driven
they were grand-slam driven so I backed
off that and I backed off that maybe
because I'm just burnt dude I just want
to get wins like I don't need to change
culture like I didn't need to change my
bank account and my lifestyle like so I
don't know to what extent I'm it's it's
like I can frame it either way am i more
mature because I'm like look I don't
have not attracted to the sexiness of it
I just want to build you know great
things great businesses or am I just
fearful and burnt out from failure it's
hard to say for me right but my view it
definitely has changed where now I'm
like oh that you on path I don't know
that sounds like a lot of effort why
don't I just do this simple thing that's
gonna like work yeah and part of me is
like okay I agree and I agree and I am
the same and then the other part is like
yeah dude but you're just kind of being
like a puss like what were the twelve
year old didn't you like think is
awesome and every once in a while you
got to listen to that and so I don't
know how I feel
[Music]